Thank You Emily I want to also take this
opportunity to welcome all of you to
this 12th annual conference on BPD and
and today's topic it gives me great
pride to actually be one of the hosts
and the administrative home for this
annual conference that you've heard a
lot about it and that it is not the
longest-running conference and I
remember when Seth started this and I'm
so proud of that that he was a junior
actually just getting done with supposed
his postdoc with me and joining the
faculty and it was his vision and his
idea he reached out to Perry Hoffman and
Perry was most gracious and and really
open to this and their vision together
has led to this and and we are very
proud to be part of that and to help
sponsor it to be the home for it and to
do what we can't really build the
network that that you're seeing
essentially bringing the family bringing
everyone that that wants to be involved
and is involved together to really
address this this very devastating
illness so I want to start by just I'll
be very brief I want to thank Seth
Axelrod and Perry Hoffman for their
dedication for their vision for really
leading the charge which has now become
a national and international phenomena
and Seth has been gracious in bringing
more and more people into the fold here
who want to be involved so he has he has
really led the way and and I want to
acknowledge that and thank you sad for
all all of your work
[Applause]
I want to acknowledge any a BPD and
Perry Hoffman and all of everything that
you've heard about the organization it
has also grown in the last 12 years in
an amazing amazing way the reach the
Internet has helped in connecting people
but but taking that on and having that
vision and really pushing it forward and
now bringing the advocacy to research
with NIH is is really important I too
want to thank Emily Ansel as Emily said
she's been with us for a long number of
years and we're very sad that Syracuse
has has stolen her but but I think
actually I'm very proud to say that I
think we're gonna continue working
together I think you'll see dr. Ansel
back here for perhaps these conferences
and as well as to offer her wisdom and
and her help so we're gonna continue to
collaborate so I'm very proud of her too
and it's a it's bittersweet so I wish
her all the best but we're very thankful
that she's been able to do really lead
the conference take the charge and
direct it and put this together so thank
you so much for taking it on really
appreciate it I also want to thank the
team of volunteers and staff who have
helped to put this conference together
we rely a lot on our pre-doctoral
psychology fellows who are part of the
Department of Psychiatry the
postdoctoral fellows the junior faculty
who went while did the Yale New Haven
psychiatric hospital the staff who were
involved in the Yale New Haven
psychiatric hospital DBT program and
also the administrators in the
psychology section in the department of
psychiatry joan creek uh and others who
really contribute to helping put this
all together and provide support to dr.
Axelrod and dr. Ansell so their
tremendous commitment and to the
conference into this area research is is
really really important I want to
acknowledge that I want to acknowledge
the Yale New Haven Hospital psychiatric
hospital the NEA BPD the Yale stress
Center the
Department of Psychiatry and of course
the Yale Medical School for their
support over the years I also want to
thank silver Hill Hospital and Clear
View treatment program for their for
being sponsors of this of this
conference and really supporting it over
the years we've really valued that I
want to take a moment and thank the
speakers thank you for taking the time
and being part of this and for spending
the day with us for for really sharing
your wisdom on this very very important
topic that brings me to today's topic
I'm just gonna say take a moment to say
how important this is assessing and
treating suicidality is critical I think
in in terms of what is happening
nationally the Centers for Disease
Control has shown data now for the last
two to three years of prevalence rates
of suicidality rising so successful
suicide as well as attempts are going up
and particularly in children and
adolescents this is a very severe and
serious and devastating set of numbers
and so I think the topic for today is
very important it shows that each of you
are committed to that and want to learn
more about it so I think this is a very
important focus and I'm looking forward
to the conference and I welcome you
again thank you for being here
[Applause]
[Music]